[Applause]
Thank You Bernadette ah and ladies and
gentlemen I can tell just breathing this
hair that you have had a very productive
day behind you so thank you for having
me in thank you to the Global Covenant
of Mayors for inviting me to speak at
the closing session today you have had a
lively discussions on the role of cities
and actions taken at local level to
promote clean energy and the transition
towards climate neutral economy you are
at the core of the transition effective
urban planning good local practices
micro financing and small-scale
innovation are essential to deliver on
the Paris agreement goals last Monday
the President of the European Commission
ocean Amanda Lyon presented the EU
ambition to make Europe the first
climate neutral continent by 2050 and in
two days the European Commission will
lay out their European clean deed and
agenda to make Europe cleaner and
cleaner but also with a more competitive
and resilient economy there are many
drivers for the European Green Deal but
I believe people better consumers or
producers of energy or workers or the
real driver of the change towards
climate neutrality well either the
European Green Deal will work for all or
it will not work at all every household
SME or industry should be able to
benefit from affordable secure and clean
and I chip each of them should be able
to express its concerns and proposals
and propose its ideas on how to make
climate neutrality happen the Global
Covenant of Mayors provides an ideal
platform to keep people center stage and
currently their voices heard in the past
year so you have seen an unprecedented
scale of
engagement at the local level local
authorities mayor's are best placed to
speak to citizens and rely their
concerns at national and European level
it would be a historical mistake to
imagine that the clean deal will be a
top-down agendas right driven by
Brussels it must closely involved
citizens through dialogue at local level
the Covenant of Mayors will have a
central role not only to providing forum
for any changes of good practices
practices but also to implement changes
locally every sector will have to
contribute and energy plays a central
role in T carburizing our economy Europe
has succeeded to get to 31 percent of
electricity produced from renewable
renewable sources and more than half
comes from low-carbon technologies and
cities will be around the table with
central governments and regional
authorities when developing the plans to
get Europe to its climate and energy
goals this is where I see the Covenant
of Mayors bringing bringing its ambition
experience and networks of cities to
contribute to the process finally I will
apply the same principles on which a
Green Deal is based in Europe also to
our global action climate transition
must be just and it must be democratic
since I have started my mandate only
last week but I already have met many
international partners and organizations
and I will put trade and I will put at
the center of my actions the external
dimension of energy policy because EU
only accounts for 9% of the global
emissions we can lead the way but we
cannot succeed unless we bring along our
partners our major international
partners and our closest neighbors and
that is why the Global Covenant is so
important for me today City diplomacy is
growing ever stronger and the global
covenant cities see
networks and partners are the key driver
for a change
the Commission is fully committed to
help the global covenant to step up its
work this means supporting the global
governance Secretariat as well as the
network of regional governance around
the world and it is with cities that
were either succeed or fail in
implementing the clean energy transition
so we are partners in achieving our
climate neutral world thank you for your
efforts and let us take global
governance to the next level thank you
[Applause]